نحن الان امام المرسى النيلي لمدينه ابو
سمبل في انتظار العبارات النيليه القادمه
والتي يستقلها السودانيون القادمون عبر
منفذ قسطل البري في اصعب من كيده كونك
تخلي دارك
بدايه الحرب في المنازل انعطاع التيار
الكهربائي الميه ما فيش ما فيش ولا حاجه
وعلى الرغم من استمرار تدفق القادمين من
السودان الى مصر باعداد كبيره الا ان هناك
من يفضل استقلال نفس الحافلات للعوده الى
السودان حاليا السودان في ازمه
واهالي الخرطوم كلهم جايين الى مصر هذا
المكان يعد مكانا للراحه للقادمين
المرهقين من السودان قبل ان يستانفوا
رحلاتهم مره اخرى سواء الى اسوان او الى
القاهره وجدت تعاون طيب جدا حقيقه من
اخواننا المصريين بنعملهم كانهم اخوات ومع
غروب الشمس تتوقف حركه العبارات النيليه
لينتظر الجميع سطوع شمس يوم جديد لكل من
يريد ان يذهب او ياتي الى الاراضي المصريه
من السودان احمد عثمان لقناتي العربيه
والحدث من مدينه ابو سمبل محافظه اسوان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات